the brief respite of a Sunday church
service after a week in the brexit
process which had very few friendly
encounters efforts to win concessions
from Brussels have so far proved
unsuccessful now the Prime Minister
hoping a fresh promise to Parliament
will be enough to win her a further
period of grace she continues attempts
to keep her deal alive the substance of
the offer a pledge that a vote this
Thursday won't be the last opportunity
for MPs to prevent the UK leaving
without a deal we're giving an assurance
that if the meaningful vote has not
taken place by the 27th of February that
in those circumstances Parliament would
have a further opportunity to debate and
vote in relation to a motion but it's
not just back benches that number 10 is
seeking to reassure there are a number
of Ministers including some within
cabinet now weighing up their options
very carefully they want to give the
Prime Minister space to try and salvage
a deal but equally they will not
countenance and no deal brexit will act
to stop it and so for them the question
is all about timing and Downing Street
hoping that by insisting that this week
is not the point of no return they can
see off the risk of potential imminent
resignations and rebellions but for
labour the offer doesn't go far enough
with the party preparing to lay an
amendment calling for a final vote this
month to prevent the Prime Minister
running down the clock until March
forcing a binary choice between her Deal
or No Deal while emplyees prepare for
the parliamentary battles ahead there
were further warnings from business
about the impact of the ongoing
uncertainty we really are in the
emergency zone of brexit now so I think
last November we have the possibility of
a deal on the table and that has now
that feels it's receded we don't have a
deal on the table
firms are having to plan in the here and
now for a No Deal brexit with all of the
pain that that will bring but according
to Tony Blair one of the architects of
the Good Friday Agreement the impact of
an Odile brexit could go far beyond
business the former prime minister
telling sky Sophie Ridge it would risk
the peace
itself it would potentially be
definitely devastating you would have a
hard border very hard border I mean a no
deal breaks it means a really hard
border between North and South in
Ireland it's contrary to the Good Friday
Agreement and it will cause a an
enormous fissure within the United
Kingdom the government insists leaving
with an agreement remains the goal and
so tomorrow brexit Secretary Stephen
Barclay will head to Brussels for his
first formal meeting with the --use
Michel Barnier talks resuming between
negotiators on a deal that both sides
had claimed could not and would not be
reopened
Tom Rainer Sky News Westminster